I'm grateful for the opportunity to talk
about what I think is a very important
topic probably now more so than ever is
with the rapid pace of investment
and the rate and pace of innovation
what are we doing to actually achieve
Roi from those investments in machine
learning and so I'll kind of break the
talk into you can call it three
different sections I'd like to tell you
what we're going to talk about up front
the first part will be a little bit
about the market what are the signals
what are we seeing what are some of the
opportunities what are some of the
challenges
then what are some of the capabilities
we need to address those challenges
and then I want to introduce the concept
of a semantic layer to you all maybe
you've heard of it maybe you haven't but
we'll talk a little bit about what's
unique about a semantic layer and how it
could potentially impact and drive Roi
to scale ML and AI investment probably
something a lot of people have not
thought about specifically with a
semantic layer before I start are there
folks familiar with the concept of a
semantic layer
okay great
um so that being said why don't we Jump
Right In
uh no that is not the slide I want to be
on
here we go
so if we start with the market I wanted
to take an approach that says before
jumping right into ML and AI how are
organizations getting better analysis
and understanding of their data and
there's a lot of different ways to show
these types of charts and maybe for the
practitioners in the room the ones that
they're most familiar with are these box
charts you know where you're going left
to right or top to bottom you're showing
data ingestion events streaming that
data gets landed into another box maybe
it's a lake house maybe it's a warehouse
it then feeds some analysis machine
learning AI there's governance there's
all these different tools and then at
the very very end maybe on the right
hand side or in a vertical oriented box
chart at the very very top there's a
little layer and there's typically some
people and some icons
and that is typically representing the
consumption layer
I didn't want to show the Box chart
because you're probably going to hear a
lot of about the tools and the
technologies that are helping fuel the
arrows from left to right or top to
bottom I want to start at that
consumption layer and maybe work our way
back because at the end of the day the
talk is about applied Ai and the talk is
about how do we deliver business impact
so it's going to ultimately come down to
how people are organizing their data and
where they're making decisions from
so those personas those tooling choices
those processes matter just as much as
all of the arrows that typically are on
those complex box charts that are before
it and potentially come after it so I
show this chart and you've probably seen
even a flavor of it you know it's not
meant to imply in you know the most
competitive companies are the ones that
are going up and to the right they are
right but that's not the entire way I
would read this chart so when you look
at the different boxes it's things that
we all understand reporting right
understanding of what happened
descriptive analysis what happened but
give me more multi-dimensional views of
it Diagnostics how it happened and why
it happened predictive what will happen
and then ultimately prescriptive what's
the best course of action I should be
taking
now it's not about picking one of these
and saying I've got to go do
prescriptive I've got to go do
predictive
it's actually looking at large mature
organizations and realizing they've
invested in all of these Technologies
and it's not one or the other it's
encompassing every aspect of the tools
and the processes they've made around
these Technologies so in a large
Enterprise mindset reporting might be
just as important as predictive and
prescriptive and for example you know
we've all been hearing a little bit
about you know finance and the
importance of a CFO in this current
economic climate battery Ventures I
think did a a report last year that said
somewhere between 73 and 80 percent of
financial analysis is still done in a
spreadsheet
so you can go build the most you know uh
perform in accurate time series model to
go build a forecast but if that forecast
isn't impacting what that financial
analyst is doing and building reports
for their CFO to then go back to their
CEO
you're likely not delivering impact for
that organization so reporting has just
as much of a equal say as all of the ml
tooling pipeline Investments you're
making up to the right
and then finally if you look at the
upper right hand side which is a
direction we want people to be moving in
I think the applied AI opportunity is
actually to become huge when we can
start to bring predictive plus
prescriptive together not in separate
tools
and when you come back to that concept I
mentioned about you know your favorite
charts and you know how you like to view
the stack
when you think about those personas the
analyst the business subject matter
experts right regardless of the industry
you're in you could either be using
popular dashboarding tools you might
have your own custom dashboards the idea
again is we want to be delivering
smarter decisions
and smarter decisions typically stem
from some form of a tool right so
there's the users how do I impact users
to make better decisions and then
there's the Systems and Technology so
you know I think as as Daniel mentioned
I've had some experience in deep
learning so
you know you think of an example like
visual search right as an online
retailer I'm doing a whole bunch of
complex analyzes I'm doing
classification models feeding detection
models generating embeddings for a
recommendation uh or feed forward
Network and at the end of the day that
thing is surfacing inside of a
visualization on some online Retailer's
website so it has to be consumable right
to that end user so predictive and
prescriptive I think can unlock a lot of
potential and you're bringing those two
technologies together but bring it
together where when and how with the
context that decisions are being made
so you know taking a slightly different
view of of the market you know let's
talk about what's hard
right and you've probably heard a lot
from different speakers on all the great
technology the Investments that we're
making and the first bullet here
basically is aligned with that right
idc's predicting and you can pick your
favorite stat you know this year alone
we're going to have 500 billion in AI
solution investment in Ai and ML and
that that makes sense right when we look
at the last eight to ten years the rate
and pace and innovation
we started with Brute Force modeling we
introduced automl we simplified that
process now we're sort of transitioning
more into ml Ops and sort of the next
phases of ml Ops and what that's
indicative of
is customers aren't or large
organizations aren't just realizing that
machine learning and AI is a nice to
have
they're not realizing that it's just
about experimentation they're realizing
this is my competitive differentiation
I've made or I am making my vendor
selection my tool selection I'm
investing in organizations perhaps I'm
investing in a chief AI officer maybe I
have a VP of data science
that's happening and that has happened
so it doesn't it's not it shouldn't be
surprising that all of that is now
coming at the cusp of the rate and pace
of the Innovation around data science
and machine learning we're seeing
but conversely when you start to look at
the impact and I love the two studies
that Gartner has done at the end of last
year
they basically studied out of the
machine learning models that have been
trained and in talking to large
Enterprises what percentage of them are
actually getting deployed
and unfortunately it's to the tune of 50
percent
right so one out of every two machine
learning models may not actually be
making it into production and they're
dying on the vine
and then even those that are making
their way into production are not
staying in production or they're not
able to achieve or impact and create
value for the for the business
so
when you take a step back we understand
okay it's all about Enterprise AI That's
what the focus is that's what we need to
be doing but at a far simpler level
we're hitting the realization that while
spend is up Roi is low because models
are not making their way into production
and there are going to be lots of
different reasons why models are not
making their way into production
I think I heard the end of the last talk
trust transparency it could be skills it
could be resources it could be available
compute infrastructure requirements
we're going to talk about a slightly
different angle on that I don't disagree
with any of those reasons as to why ml
models are not making their way into
production but we're going to hit a far
simpler approach which is models need to
be used by business decision makers and
we're going to try to understand what
that means in the context of this talk
so these are somewhat startling numbers
maybe people aren't as startled but the
question now is
is this pervasive is this a trend should
this be a focus for you know large
Enterprise and individuals
another recent study that was done at
the end of last year by MIT tech review
basically interviewed 600 global cios
ctOS and cdos from around the world and
they asked them very simple questions on
what their data management strategy is
over the next few years
and what does that mean for business
value
and the priorities are pretty clear
right over three quarters of leaders
surveyed said that scaling Ai and
machine learning use cases to create
business value is the top priority of
their Enterprise data strategy for the
next three years
top priority
right so this is now not just about
investment and spend
I think the realization that you know
with the economic environment we're in
with all the the spend that we have in
machine learning AI it's it's time for
return on investment right and so that's
where the focus is we're going to start
to see over the next few years and it
also makes sense why you know ml Ops
companies are also on the rise right we
have a we have our say in how to make ml
Ops and machine learning models stay in
production and Achieve value
but we have to do a little bit more
so before we kind of get into the
capabilities required I am I feel like a
professor here just because we're in
this room but I I wanted to do a very
brief like my brief version of what has
happened in AI over the last couple of
years and sort of how it's changed
because that's going to help us
understand when we come back to the
Enterprise and we come back to that
chart that goes up and to the right how
do I overlay and marry some of the rate
and pace of innovation back to the
Investments That core Enterprises are
making but have already made right
that's how you're going to be impactful
it's not just about sandbox environments
it's how do I get into core processes
right it's not even just about
applications how do I get to where
businesses are running I want the thing
that's going to run a million times a
day not the thing that runs once and I'm
done for another couple of months
so to understand how AI has changed I'll
start with maybe the early days and the
early days I would say are actually
still here too
um but you know if you think back 15 20
years a lot of this was Advanced
analytics and statistics right
statistical inferences you were picking
your selections your algorithm maybe you
were using Bayesian methods you know
maybe you started looking at Hadoop and
flat file systems at the Advent of Big
Data maybe you were starting to work
with spark as an analytic runtime
chances are you were working on Prem but
it was a very manual brute force method
and you were spending a lot of time in
ETL and cleansing of that data before
you apply your statistical models
and then what started to change around
let's call it 2008 2010 we started to
see these automl and low code platforms
start to get introduced right so it
alleviated the burden of all that manual
process right I got help with my
algorithmic selection hyper parameter
tuning became became simpler right and
uh my feature engineering and my feature
analysis and extraction and feature
impact reports all of that started to
manifest in these tools because they
wanted to elevate an upscale data
scientists and the term data scientists
started to become more important around
this time and the notion was well I just
upload a CSV like upload and go right
and those automl platforms did fairly
well and they're still continuing to do
well and as a result of training
right the emphasis on the training
pipeline around 2008-2010 that's when we
started to see more experimentation and
we started to see more model building
and then as those models started to
transition to deployment it became more
about the runtime and that's where we
started to see ml Ops start to rise more
and around this time I would say cloud
and SAS became more popular right this
was
2010 2012 around that time frame
and then where we are today and I know
these are very big logical leaps and a
lot of things have happened in between
right we see a lot more around Edge iot
especially in the Advent of deep
learning with computer vision
generative AI you know we can't escape
that hype right now but just remember
generative Ai and some of the networks
and models are not necessarily new T5
have been around for a while Bert's been
around for a while but what's new
is the way you access build train and
deploy right so open source has now
become much more prevalent private apis
are no longer the way that you're
interacting with deep learning and
perhaps even large language models and
now it's more of how do I take advantage
of the compute infrastructure that I
have and how can I also bring model
model training and even your run time
closer to where that compute lives today
so very similar to what we talked about
on that first slide it's not really an
if or or it's they're probably doing
some level of all of this inside of a
large mature Enterprise and every
Enterprise is going to be somewhere
different on the Spectrum but for the
large Enterprises we've talked to we're
actually seeing multiple Investments
here
automl tools
feature stores which have become new uh
investments in deep learning
private Cloud VPC deployments right it's
all over the Spectrum and that spectrum
is indicative of the workloads they're
running batch online real time
structured unstructured so again the
reason why I'm bringing this up is the
problem for a business impact at an
Enterprise level is far more than what
am I doing in my automl tool it has a
ripple effect on all of those different
processes and tools that I've invested
in from the get-go
so coming back to the core thesis of of
the conversation it's about business
impact so we kind of have an idea of
what's going on in the market lots of
rate and change a lot of investment
machine learning and AI is advancing
very very quickly open source momentums
moving
but if one of the core things an
Enterprise is trying to do one of is to
make better decisions
better decisions typically require some
form of intelligence
and when we think about intelligence we
think about machine learning pipelines
model building training and deployment
so
conditional you know if P then Q Logic
says well if I want better decisions or
I'm trying to achieve better decisions I
need some form of intelligence if I want
intelligence I need some sort of
predictive capability that's going to
help me Aid
that decision
then business decisions really are
predicated on predictive intelligence
now that seems pretty straightforward
pretty easy to understand and pretty you
know something that we should be doing
but the challenge again from the
beginning has been not building
predictive intelligence and creating
inferences or predictions it's how do I
make those predictions and inferences
available to business decision makers
where they're making business decisions
when they're making business decisions
with the context they're making business
decisions in and the tldr and the
spoiler alert is that's not in a Jupiter
notebook that's not in a low code
platform that's not an end-to-end AI
platform and it's not in an ml Ops
dashboard
coming back to that Finance example it's
still in spreadsheets it's still in
common bi tools like power bi Tableau
click microstrategy right business the
users the business decision makers and
users still live in those tools today
and systems and processes that's we can
have a separate conversation on how
predictive should influence the
automation of some of those processes
but from the standpoint of making this
decisions with business decision makers
at an Enterprise level
that's happening typically in more
structured
environments
so
we need predictive output so now we're
in the capabilities section of of the
talk what do I need from a capability
standpoint to help address business
impact so that I can Aid and Infuse
predictive artifacts predictive metadata
predictive
tables
to decision makers well those
predictions first and foremost should be
relevant right so if I'm living in a
tool that's not an ml pipeline or a
distributed ml pipeline if I'm in a
custom dashboard my own dashboard how do
I know that as my the Dynamics of my
business are changing the predictions
that are being generated in a
distributed ml environment are still
relevant to me right think of like high
volatility stock trading think of even
underwriting I mean it's not a great
example but interest rate changes
overnight right how do I know that the
decision maker or the views that are
being generated in my tools and
Reporting chain right that you know from
all the way from
reporting to descriptive
how do I know that what I'm generating
in that distributed ml pipeline is still
relevant
and then more importantly even if I'm
able to maintain relevance how do I
consume that natively in that tool I
don't I'm an analyst
and a lot of the automl platforms will
say we cater to analysts but let's be
real an analyst is not going into an
automl platform to make a decision so
how do I publish and automate
the publishing of ml metadata active ml
metadata back to the business in their
tools of choice
and then finally how do I make it
explainable and it's not explainable in
the context of the conversation you guys
had before it's in business terminology
right so business users are not thinking
in terms of area under the curve F1
score they're thinking in terms of
product customer net revenue
profitability so I want to understand
that ml metadata and those ml artifacts
in that context right which are more
along the lines of dimensions and
measures and hierarchies which is how a
business user is framing and using and
interacting in their tools of choice
so let's use a very very simple example
to kind of illustrate this point and by
the way this is based off of some real
Enterprise customers so I'm the owner of
a brick and mortar retail store
I sell goods and I ask my Logistics and
supply chain team forecast future sales
for me pretty common
what would that team might do well
they'll probably have some data
scientists there's going to be maybe
some time series modeling they're going
to look at some historical data
but the challenge before they go and do
all of that
I'll call it ml work
there's some dimensions of the data and
cardinality of the data that's going to
be very important even for the ml work
that they're doing so the the first step
would be well how are we defining sales
how are we defining Revenue I asked my
supply chain and Logistics team they
happen to be using I think this is power
bi desktop they're using power bi
desktop great
their definition of sales and revenue
might be very different than finance's
definition of sales and revenue which
might also be very different than the
sales teams definition of sales and
revenue and what's worse is each one of
those teams might also be using
different tools so my sales team might
be using a popular CRM tool
my supply chain team is using power bi
desktop
and let's just pick on Excel or you know
Google Sheets I know my finance team
regardless of what you give them there's
someone that's still building logic
inside of those spreadsheets so now I
have a consistent view of the data
problem what is the actual single
version of the truth on those very
common attributes and you might say well
who cares gaurav I'm building a time
series model why does that matter well
it matters because you're still doing
feature engineering and then let's go
back to the to the fact that maybe
you're doing a Time series forecast that
implies you're working with time in a
Time relative measure
how are you defining time as a data
scientist maybe your Finance
counterparts are not using a fiscal
calendar maybe they're using a 554
calendar maybe the business week starts
on a Sunday not on a Monday right so
anyone who's actually built and deployed
ml models and are keeping them in
production know that even these small
nuances
while they seem pretty little can have a
massive ripple effect on the retraining
that you're going to have to do with
your data sets once you've deployed and
realized there's something wrong and
this is going to be costly and time
consuming
so what do we do
well this is the third part of the talk
let's introduce the concept of a
semantic layer and I'll tell you how
this can start to bridge to what I just
described so if you've not heard of a
semantic layer it sounds like some
people have
I did two searches the second one mainly
because of this the context of this uh
this venue but the first one was I did a
Google Search and Wikipedia came back
with a result a semantic layer is a
business representation of corporate
data that helps end users access data
autonomously using common business terms
and I accentuated and bolded some of
these components because I actually
think this is a very good and accurate
definition so if we take a step back
business representation of corporate
data
to me that means business friendly
I shouldn't have to require a SQL expert
to help me understand my own data
access data autonomously that seems a
lot like self-service I shouldn't have
to read it or data architect to work
with my data
and then using common business terms
that to me is business relativity right
so they're not thinking in row or column
equals 10. most of these business users
are thinking in customer product sales
churn different types of semantics
and then for you know for uh for context
I also asked chat GPT Give me the
definition of a semantic layer sure
enough it gave a pretty accurate
definition I'll let you guys read it but
we'll talk more on this next slide on
some of the things that even chat GPT
brought up
now that you have a little bit of an
understanding of what a semantic layer
is where does it fit in the stack
and the first thing I'll tell you is the
concept of a semantic layer is not
actually new
semantic layers have existed since the
early 90s when business objects started
talking about business universe and
historically they've been tied to bi
tools or data platforms
right so if you look at Tableau or
looker or even power bi
these tools have their own versions of a
semantic layer that work natively and
are coupled
to those platforms and then conversely
if you're looking at a data platform
maybe you're using you know The
Medallion architecture and you're going
from bronze to silver to gold where gold
now becomes the tables that are part of
your consumption View
a lot of folks in that sort of mindset
Define those tables as a semantic layer
now the challenge with using either one
of these types of semantic layers is in
the case of the bi tool even if you
start with a view of a semantic layer
that's coupled to a bi tool you still
have to understand the physical data
that it's being connected to and that's
going to require complex SQL and
probably data modelers
and then inversely if you start with the
data platform
you're going to often work in a very
rigid environment and then it's that
last mile of analytics that's now
required to get that published the
consumption layer that you're going to
have to manually be dealing with
so with all of that
we introduce the concept of an
independent Universal semantic layer
and the idea here with a universal
semantic layer is it does four key
distinctive things one it helps you
create a common definition of business
logic your Dimensions your measures the
things the actuals that your business is
measuring their kpis off of
two it makes it easier
to augment to add to create businesses
are Dynamic things change you should be
able to effectively modify and augment
those business metrics so we need a
simple way to do that
third
you can connect to all of the tools you
want you can be as universal if you want
but if you don't have performance
no one's going to use you
right so a universal semantic layer not
only has the understanding and
wherewithal to understand different
dialects of different tools that are
connecting to it it also understands the
dialect of the sequel of the underlying
Warehouse that it's running on and the
power of that is any query that's coming
in automatically gets pushed down for
Price performance compute efficiency to
that underlying Warehouse meaning
we are not extracting data data stays in
your backend system and we'll talk about
why that's also important for AI in a
second
and then finally the fourth point is
even if I can get consistent views of
the data even if I can create augment
and change metrics as my business needs
to
and as I start to get price performance
I still have to have governance and
control right so that's a big theme of
this you know conference so how you do
authentication protocols all of that has
to work with a semantic layer as well
maybe you're publishing to a catalog
right a universal semantic layer should
have apis that are extensible so that
you can publish things like XML and
create views in your catalog so that as
you're doing Downstream policies policy
management you have that single version
of the truth that's being published to
other Downstream systems
so how do we sort of take this to the
next level and how does this now start
to influence what we're doing with
machine learning and AI
the concept of universal semantic layer
is what we're focusing on at skill and
you can think of it as a logical layer
that sits between your consumption tools
and your backend systems
and now we have a single place to Define
business logic within the Enterprise
regardless of the tools regardless of
the back ends and it gives us a distinct
Advantage because there's two types of
metadata that we're going to start to be
interacting with and we call it passive
and active metadata and the reason why I
like to show this slide is as we're
transitioning more to Cloud you start to
hear clouds are becoming you know the
center of data right data gravity is
going to the cloud
we have a very similar analogy that says
well knowledge knowledge gravity should
shift to a semantic layer
right we need that Universal point and
consistency
so what we start to build is views into
managing and manipulating passive
metadata right cardinality of my data
where it's stored how it's structured
where is the data coming from what's the
granularity and the size of the data
that I'm working with pretty typical
metadata that you know you would have
seen in maybe any one of these talks
where we extend it to is now what we're
calling active metadata so active
metadata is I'm in my bi tool I'm making
changes I'm publishing new artifacts I'm
building new measures for the business
where do I reflect that and how do I
ensure that when I build something new
that that gets propagated to all of the
other Downstream tools that are now
connected and require it and then more
importantly
a universal semantic layer shouldn't
just be focusing on BI specific dialects
a universal semantic layer should also
be able to talk to distributed ML and AI
pipelines so this is where the concept
of AI specific libraries start to come
in
python as an example can be another
dialect that now a universal semantic
layer can employ as a first-class
citizen within its ecosystem and what
that allows you to do is a Connect into
any python-based environment that's
being used that could be for data
engineering purposes that could be for
data science purposes but and I'll talk
about those capabilities in a second but
to me this becomes the important aha
moment of
business impact is still going to come
from business logic that business logic
needs predictive capabilities and
predictive artifacts but those artifacts
are only going to be impactful as the
business logic that they're assigned to
right
so
now let's get more into detail on the
next level deeper on what are we doing
with a universal semantic layer to scale
machine learning AI based on everything
we just talked about
so if you think again of a universal
semantic layer as that business metrics
layer right this is where your logic is
being defined there's two different ways
and two different types of personas that
we see could use and benefit from that
logic
so the first are I'll call them
developers data scientists data
engineers and we have a term called
manage features the concept of that is
once you've defined the business logic
inside of your Universal semantic layer
that should be an input to your
developer if you're a data engineer
you're probably managing complex data
pipelines and you want a more
programmatic way to interface and
interact
with your data and your business logic
this becomes a way to do that that's
tied
to all of the other tools that you're
already working with so you're never
working on outdated data
and you're always using the most
refreshed view that's controlled and
governed
but for this room the other developer
that we often talk to are data
scientists so especially when it comes
to things like structured tabular data
Centric AI you're working off of data
and you're extracting data into some
tool some data frame in some distributed
pipeline
Why move the data why not leave the data
inside of your data warehouse one of
your most price performant powerful
systems that were designed to do data
manipulation
and use that now as an input so there
are different ways a data scientist can
interact with our managed features
capability you can directly access and
pull business defined features or
business defined logic directly
through python
or maybe you're using a feature store so
our Universal semantic layer would
effectively be publishing business logic
to a feature store which would then be
the point that a data scientist comes in
and starts to read and write from that
feature store but the idea is we are
scaling developers within their training
pipelines by giving them access to
business relevant actuals they shouldn't
have to be redefining logic they
shouldn't have to extract more data than
is necessary
right and they shouldn't have to
duplicate logic so in that forecasting
example they'll know exactly what key
measures they'll know exactly what the
key dimensions are and they'll know
exactly the hierarchies that they should
be working off of as they start to build
their time series model and then more
importantly we know that that's not
going to be enough right the business
features or the logic that's defined
inside of a semantic layer is just an
input now they can augment that with any
of their other feature analysis right
for their hyper parameter tuning for
their various slas that they're going to
start to control
so that sort of
capability one
capability 2 is more focused on the
runtime
and it's about how do we publish
ml metadata that lives in a distributed
ml pipeline back into a universal
semantic layer
and why would we do that because mostly
what's connected to a universal semantic
layer are business friendly tools so now
if I can incorporate that metadata back
into the semantic layer my business
analyst who knows nothing about an ml
pipeline nothing about ml model metrics
can very quickly ad hoc hit refresh in
their dashboard and quickly augment
historicals with now live predictive
data
so the first capability we introduce
here we call it semantic predictions
the concept is in your distributed
runtime environment you have some model
serving capability we don't care what
that is
provided you can talk to a python-based
environment you point us to those live
prediction tables
we'll take those predictions and we'll
write them back into our semantic layer
when we automate that right we call it a
write-back when we automate that right
back we give you the flexibility to join
that to anything that's already been
defined inside of our semantic layer
so perhaps there's a dimension store
Dimension maybe there's a customer
Dimension or a customer measure that
you're interested in you're not just
writing back prediction sets you're
writing back predictions that now live
as a first-class citizen inside of a
table-oriented infrastructure that can
now be queried and sliced and diced
immediately
and I'll show you an example of what
this looks like on the next slide but
the concept here is how do we bring that
predictive
Insight that doesn't live in a bi tool
or in a dashboarding tool into a bi
dashboarding tool without replicating or
creating complexity right everything is
still staying controlled in the same
environment
and then finally the last capability we
have is called on-demand inference
so imagine now you're an analyst sitting
inside of a dashboard and you just got
the request for me I want to forecast
future sales in the prior example I said
we were going to point to a distributed
runtime and you were going to write the
predictions back to us
here
we take an ml model that's been trained
by some distributed data science team
and we register that inside of our
semantic layer
and so what we're doing is when an
analyst comes into their tool and they
start to interact with measures and the
things that they're commonly using day
to day
in addition to getting and getting some
feedback right from that measure they're
also triggering the deployment and run
time of that ml model by using at scale
or our semantic layer and the underlying
database and Warehouse
so what the the user experiences a
prediction table or a prediction set
coming back live
what's actually happening under the
covers is they're running an ml model
using a universal semantic layer
so how that sort of manifests back into
my example this is a real example
I wrote back predictions from my
distributed ml environment it was a Time
series model and it's a little hard to
read but what they were able to do was
very quickly pull that predictive table
and the predictions alongside their
actuals they created a very simple error
calculation and they said show me
actuals versus predicted over the last
30 days over the last 60 days over the
last 90 days
right from within power bi desktop
and the beauty here is when data changes
when your inputs change all you're doing
is hitting refresh because the universal
semantic layer because it's connected to
those complex data pipelines knows that
the data has changed and so we have ways
on how we do things like model
versioning with your distributed ml
environment so that we always know that
your ml models and the versions of those
ml models that you're running are
consistent with the latest data that the
business is using and there's feature
store Integrations that we're working
with there as well but the idea here is
now I'm empowering that analyst who
lives in this dashboard to start making
more predictive plus prescriptive
decisions natively within their tool
without ever stepping foot into a
distributed ml environment and the
question we often get asked is well some
of these tools start to do that they
have built-in forecasts
and I'd say sure are you going to trust
a bi tools ability to generate a ml
forecast or would you rather take
advantage of the ml investment that
you've already made inside your
Enterprise you've built a Coe you've
built a distributed data science team
you have data scientists in your line of
business you have a VP of data science
let them do the work let's
productionalize those models Faster by
getting the predictions in the hands of
business users to almost a B test
right and get these models into
production
so I I'm kind of at the end here but I
wanted to add a little bit of generative
AI context since I know we're here and
it's an area
um I'm very excited about but when we
come back and take a step back
we talked a lot about processes and
applications and different types of
workloads I think for generative AI to
have Enterprise impact they're going to
have to have the context of the things
we were just talking about right Office
365 and GitHub co-pilot and Bing are
great first examples of applications
that can start to leverage large
language models but when you talk to
large distribution or manufacturing
companies how am I going to do ticket
handling ticket routing underwriting
expense management right some of the
core day-to-day processes that are
effectively running the business how do
how does generative AI start to
influence and impact that environment
and then as we think about how that's
going to be possible
the context of a lot of this talk has
been around context
right so Ai and the ability to impact
your business is only going to be as
good as the context you have of the
business so if we want generative AI to
start taking off right we need to one
move outside of a private endpoint which
we're starting to see and I think we're
going to start to see more contributions
in the open source but context is still
required in different spots between your
date your complex data pipelines and
your ml pipelines so for example when
we're labeling data right there's big
discussions on if I'm using synthetic
data
how what does that mean for an
organization that has their own private
data sets in-house right is there
context awareness that they need
governance I think is going to change as
a result of generative AI right how do I
gain visibility auditability trans
traceability within my end-to-end data
and ml Pipelines
when I have these new language models
being introduced and then sort of
everybody's favorite topic on ethics I
think this is going to be a pretty hot
topic probably for the next couple of
years
um on bias and again having more
business context around these large
language models as they're getting
trained as computers intensive as they
are is going to help go a long way to
make sure that these models aren't
biased and are not introducing bias when
they're deployed
and then finally you know when we think
back to that very first slide up and to
the right was prescriptive and
predictive
how do we bring large language models in
generative AI more in the augmented
intelligence space and I see sort of
Office 365 as the first interesting step
there targeting sort of business users
and very business friendly tools
but what are the next set of tools that
we need to start augmenting to make that
possible
so I know I think I might be at time
um I hope you found this useful and my
goal is at the end of this you at least
have a better understanding of what's
happening in machine learning and AI
maybe some of the pitfalls that are
preventing people who have invested
highly in it from getting return and
maybe you'll start to look at a semantic
layer to say hey this is something that
can help me both on my bi metric store
and my ability to control metadata more
generically in my Enterprise and it has
added value and benefit for scaling my
machine learning initiatives
thank you
[Music]